which is live coverage of an African
safari and may include animal kills and
caucuses viewer discretion is advised
this is why the inclement ride is such a
firm favorite
[Music]
he just looks ready for a fight this is
still her territory good afternoon and
welcome everybody from all over the
world wherever you might be tuning in to
this the 16th episode of Safari laughs
my name is Steve Faulconbridge I'm join
a camera by VM the Valle de beers please
pop in your questions or comments down
below we have had an amazing week so far
I've come back from leave and the week
has just been absolutely splendid let's
go and see how our characters have been
performing this week down here in juma
this week the little chief asana kept
his usual activities balanced between
the game rich Gallagher and boy Attila
pans the wild dog family arrived and
rumor from the north in the early week
keeping to the west of Gallagher pan
there exited into buffer look for the
night but returned the following morning
south of our camp an unknown female
leopard moves the juma from the east the
tracks led us to Cheng Anna who appeared
north of where Telepan the Duke and this
unknown female moved together as deadly
Eastern to Torchwood the Oklahoma pride
made an appearance in our southwestern
boundary and an ax of hyena den sites
has been discovered in the heart of Juma
up in the mara triangle the team were
able to locate to Kenya in the South
close to the Tanzanian border the
sausage tree pride was not far away to
the west while kinky tail away from the
pride was seen even further west with
one of the old Anya pay ik mails the
North clan kept the usual domain west of
the Mara River has been and we are going
to be spending this entire two hours
going through everything of excitement
from wild dogs for sana a new hyena den
site on the property as well as all the
excitement that's happening up in the
north with the Maasai Mara and talking
about the Maasai Mara we would really
like to be going up there shortly
because not only do we have lots of
action here during the week that we are
playing back for you
things are happening live in the moment
and if we do go all the way up there it
can be very exciting to see some male
lions interacting with David ghee to all
the way up in the beautiful and pristine
Masai Mara
welcome to the Masai Mara triangle and
we are in Kenya and how lucky to start
with a pair of lions here and male in a
female under some shade of some torture
tree we have been following these lions
since this morning
and as usual my name is David and remain
camera is Manu Manu good afternoon what
dramatic that has been we have been
following this line since morning and
the one you see on the right for those
who have never joined us before is
called Kapali and the females come from
another pride of lions that is called
you know that is a clear sign of a
meeting or female in East Rose and we
might be lucky just start with us
tomorrow and we might see the mating
it's just much of time before that
happens the reason why maybe the male
could not be interested at the moment he
is very tired he has been involved with
two fights today one in the morning and
another one this afternoon
great temperatures we got here in the
Mara about 27 degrees Celsius and 87
degrees Fahrenheit and remember this is
a very interactive Safari Drive you
doing and you're welcome to ask as many
questions as you may wish in the
comments you may have please tweet and
send them through hashtag safari live
and don't forget to keep following us in
the YouTube chat sim it's time for
Kabuli in the mail to take a break as I
said earlier he had some two epic
battles one in the morning and one in
the afternoon the two young males that
came around that we have never seen
before and our guest me and Manoir and
the tumors were nomadic and ideally
that's very typical for lions when they
won't recover from an area or pride of
lions
area they will definitely muscle out
with existing males or the coalition
there and he fully belongs to what you
call the sausage tree coalition he's in
general the largest in size and stronger
than they are the two boys he is always
with so these two nomadic males they
knew the target and they knew who to
deal with among us the three they chose
carefully because he is the guy in
charge in the morning key pulley so one
off and I think he was suicide I saw him
running for about two miles non-stop
dealing with the other one
the yawn that's a great question well
tell you Kapali was chasing a young lion
which we think was nomadic is a male
lion and I think that's the one they're
not that were one particular one this is
the second that was just chased maybe
another one hour ago but Diane the one
that was just away alia was a pneumatic
mail that I have never seen and my guess
is because I'm based in Kenya in the
Mara triangle that somatic mail came
from a national park called Serengeti in
the countries south of Kenya called
Tanzania
so is a male I've never seen before
apparently he had half a tail and key
pulley dealt with him accordingly this
morning now one other male that we have
just seen from a distant stayed back
with his female here and have been
meeting the whole day he pulley came and
said about a hundred metres away from
them under some shade of Gdynia tree
cooling off
loulou depending on age of the female
old male or more age being the factor is
always anything between 5 to 10 days the
mating will continue anything 5 to 10
days they'll be meeting and the first
few days we have seen the mating like 60
or 70 times in a day and as the
honeymoon continues you know the
frequency fades out by Loulou anything 5
to 10 days we have seen lions the
longest I would say they would stay
together would be about 10 days at times
is only five days meetings over and then
they go separate days I mean separate
ways so after Coppola Kim from the shed
this afternoon he thought now he was
really energized and ready to face the
other male and it did not take long
before he saw the other male off and now
he's happily rejoined or gotten you know
his female back I'll think we'll keep
staying here and watch how is going to
play out but my other brother in South
Africa steve-o is hunting for other
predators
thank you very much David indeed I
believe the dance moves are impeccable
up in the Mara
maybe Senzo it needs to go back up there
and learn a couple I know he knows most
of the dance moves around so how
fantastic is that to be seeing all sorts
of mating going on and nomads being
chased by dominant males something I
really miss a lot is spending time with
lions we I will be heading up to the
Mara in about a week so I will be with
Lions soon no dart in there multitudes
so exciting to be learning all about
them up there but this afternoon we
myself and VM are trying to see if we
can find that wild dog family they were
up it before suc this morning and
possibly there might come down there
might be a movement down back in towards
Dumas we're just doing a little bit of a
patrol up to the north see if any
activity does come down it's been very
special to have them this week very very
special indeed as the new puppies are
following around the adults and the
adults are having all sorts of
interaction with them with bringing them
little presence
I got my first view of the wild dog
puppies early on Wednesday morning or
six pups playfully pool that what turned
out to be a Steinbach head after much
play from pups and adults alack the pack
settled on some shade to escape the heat
all of a sudden one of the adult males
ran off after skulking hyena who dared
come too close away from the protection
of their den the answers will be faced
with many challenges to survival in this
harsh environment the puppies learned
two valuable lessons namely the
importance of strength in numbers and an
attack can be the best form of Defense
so incredible to have found them and I
think my second day back from leave wild
dog puppies first time in my life seeing
them and we've got to spend some amazing
time with them the entire morning that
day in fact and then the entire evening
as well as they moved to and from and
how as those little youngsters playing
with a little prize the adults have
brought them a Steinbach Head which is
something that they do once they devour
kill somewhere further away they often
brings something back just to show them
we've been out and these are the
groceries we've provided for you but at
the same time they also Gurjit a it's an
enormous amounts of their carcass for
them because they can't lose that to a
hyena or a lion
once it's in their tummy but then they
bring the prize back maybe to show the
youngsters well this is what meat you
eating today so I suppose they can
recognize it next time and be like ooh I
quite enjoyed a little bit of that so
track their female leopard coming in
from the north we had some tracks this
morning of tiny just down the road here
which we are we ran out of time to try
and follow but maybe we'll have some
luck a little bit later she has been of
a char this week or maybe we just been
too busy with other things but so
fantastic to be with the wild dogs and
they have been in the north as I said to
be hopefully we'll get to them but
another character who is on the show
every single week Sidney himself has
gone out this afternoon and he's found
the little chief
look at that this is beautiful you can
see husana is now trying to leak a very
fresh kill we are so very lucky we just
got here shortly after the kill when he
was dragging the kill up into the tree
you can see now he is looking for a
better spot at the moment and there are
some hyenas we just got arrived now
about a second ago I can see they are
looking at him you can see that he is
now also concentrating much more towards
this study it's looking very much tired
because killing an animal is a very big
job for an individual when he went up to
that tree he went up very fast
I could see that something is coming he
saw the hyenas and decided to run up
into this tree in order to avoid
competition a very very good afternoon
and welcome to the episode 19 of the
Safari live my name is Sydney former
enemy Cosi I am traveling with Senzo who
is my camera operator this afternoon and
we are going to try by all means to give
you the best experience ever for your
questions and comments you can follow us
on twitter hashtag safari live you can
also follow us on youtube chat stream it
seems like today is going to be a very
interesting day because my plan was to
look for husana as well as visiting the
new den
this is amazing look at that you can see
that the keel is still very much fresh
it is an Impala female Impala and now I
can see that Isana is gaining some
little bit of strength and is trying by
all means to move the Kaka's fader up he
has not even yet started feeding on this
Impala
he has just been successful just now we
have just missed this action and gas who
informed me about this a little Squealer
is the one who was giving quite a lot of
alarm call and I was good as I was
looking around I managed to see husana
moving away holding a kill right on his
mouth he's trying to open the stomach of
this little Impala day but it seems to
be very difficult
Rosina
I can guarantee you now if China comes
here now asana is not going to be able
to defend his kill because I can see
that it looks very much tired but now
you can see that he's still at the
beginning stage of eating these cutters
he's trying now to take off all the
hairs he's using his tongue in order to
scrap all the hairs there as the tongue
of this kind of cares they are very
coarse and the consisted of quite a lot
of spines which helps them to get rid of
this ass
it doesn't want to get quite a lot of
hair balls in the stomach so you can see
there is quite a lot of open hairs there
now waste licking at the moment you can
see some of the hairs they are now
starting to fly away look at that it's
doing a great job
look at that so when it's doing this
what is doing now
sometimes they absorb they even swallow
some of these hairs and these hairs are
going to the stomach and develop a very
nice ball and afterwards you will see
them in the form of hairball sometimes
you can see them as a very long string
coming out look at that he nearly lost
his caucus and the hyenas are just here
I am just looking to where his highness
I can't see them anymore here Catherine
what attracts the a hyenas and the other
predators after a kill is quite a lot of
factors one when the animal is dying
does give a distress call when the
animal is giving call such as a
that is when the creditors in the area
starts to come and investigate and apart
from that some of these animals such as
the hiders they are so were gifted in
such a way that they can be able to
detect from a sense of smell they can
easily detect blood so you can see that
these animals they've got quite a lot of
things to do after a kill you can see
before we even start opening this animal
we must have to first get rid of the
hairs which is quite a very long process
and all these needs a lot of energy so
imagine if someone comes here after
losing quite a lot of energy like this
is he going to manage to defend these
carcass definitely not he won't have
enough energy to defend this so I can
see how that carcass is lying there it
might fall at any time earlier this week
we saw Zara trying to catch some food
earlier this week we found wasana trying
his luck with a game of cat and Mongoose
[Music]
our favorite little chief was up to his
usual curious antics and was chasing
some terrified mongoose around a fallen
tree they did the best avoid his claws
while shouting their disapproval at the
big head bouncing above them
unlike os honest success from last week
around the juma pen he did not manage to
catch the little creatures and
eventually give up and moved on the
terrified Mongoose made each these kind
of a predate as used to catch these big
big animals but the small animals are
confusing him a lot as they were going
inside the burrows one after each other
they were just going just like that that
was amazing so you can see now he's
eating the tail and the tail it's got
quite a lot of hairs
I'm sure he's gonna cut that last part
of the tail Chris is not going to get
rid of all the hairs from this animal
he's just taking the accessible parts
once the animal is opened it will now
consider it from the intestine and some
of this skin they will still be there
it's still gonna eat some of these
things some will be processed and come
back in the form of hair balls
so you can see that husana is now
improving his hunting skills which is
very good and a lack of the fact that he
is very fast he doesn't want the other
species such as the highness to come and
disturb him you can see those hind legs
they are so very powerful so they can be
able to propel this animal when he is
lifting up these carcass look at that
he's battling to arrange this caucus
very well so I hope he's not going to
lose this caucus so now let's go to the
Masai Mara David has got another big cat
David is having the Lions at the moment
not to show if the Lions are sleeping or
they are showing some of the afternoon
activities or sana was made very fast
little punch to see in South Africa a
couple of months ago but now from a
distance I do not know whether you can
see very well but I would say down to
the left of your screen somewhere there
there's a little pad of something that
looks like a lion and that is the
dejected loser who was dealt with
perpendicularly by Kapali
the male and he's watching from a
distance as Kapali is having the best of
his life and between the time you saw me
last and now he pulley actually has
emitted two times will you believe that
I think is very frustrated and I'm sure
both of them the direction they are
looking at is where that other male is
and I'm sure you fully want to send some
clear message to the nomadic male I'm in
charge here I've bitten you away you go
and I'm doing what you're doing and I'll
do it even better
not sure what the female is thinking as
I said earlier I think she was torn
between Khopoli
and the younger male that had all was
flexing muscles to fight he pulled it
off so what will happen I guess yes they
will stay together for quite some time
and I think had a question from Loula
how long will they be together as they
mate and I said 5 to 10 days so these
particular ones here it could be if he
Polly just came in he might want to
extend it just to give a bad feeling to
the other male and they may not even
move from whether you are they mean stay
there and keep on showing the other male
I'm going to met with this female here
this is my area and nobody's in charge
apart for me
in the morning I was looking for the two
youngsters that forms the sausage etre
coalition and they're nowhere to be seen
and if you have been here
my guess is capably would have an easier
fight getting rid of the two males
together
Puma the first episode or the first
drama in the morning was just chase and
space in order to host his kill but is
difficult I I saw that he nearly lost
that kill twice you can see now that
kill is falling slowly falling if you
look at how he's balancing with a big
stem from this tree and animal falling
on the other side there this is quite a
big animal already I can see that is
starting to open to get all of the
intestine it's not easy for this cat to
hold these suckers
against the tree maybe that is a better
spot now that is my wish as well as I
can see that he lost quite a lot of
energy if any other animal comes here
and take these he is going to be very
hungry
so I think he must have to have an
opportunity to reap the benefits after
such a very job well done
so now let's go back to Steve for some
updates how fantastic
from asana you little chief you little
devil another Impala
but the Lions stole his Impala last
night folks and well he's not going to
be outdone his guys just catch himself
another one so we've been checking for
those wild dogs to see if they're coming
in but at the same time we also tried to
see if we can pick up on any tracks of
the pride that we were following this
morning they gave us a little bit of a
runaround I'm not sure exactly where
they've gone to but while we're
searching we're constantly on the
lookout for tracks such a beautiful
afternoon a very nice 31 degrees Celsius
but 86 degrees Farenheit are wonderful
to be art but the excitements of the
week did not end with their first
sighting of the dogs we managed to
follow them that the night before they
disappeared into the north and Subaru
commit ourself and since they were very
fortunate to find them again in the
morning once again with the prize for
the youngsters
the air was filled with excitement when
we located the pack in the heart of Juma
the pups squabbled over a prize Abroad
nerds out from a recent killed by the
adults after much deliberation of some
serious investigation that also took the
answers to the kill judging by the
nervous approach it is possible that
this is the first actual caucus that the
pups have been to the adults wasting the
time digging in as the pups approached
that also taught them some important
table manners
after the meal the entire pack engaged
in some rather entertaining play scene
who could be king of the turmeric
mountain how incredible was that I was
driving along not expecting to see wild
dogs that morning the morning before
people had sent a request said we'd love
to see what have dogs and sausage sure
and we found them and then the next
morning people sent the same request I
said what are the chances there's not
much of a chance of finding them again
and they lo and behold traveling lights
just saw this frittering whitetail
through the bush as one of the adults
was running directly towards well in
this direction we moved in we found the
puppies the adults had obviously been
and made a kill that killed a female in
parlor and they'd obviously disemboweled
her and brought the young fetus which is
quite sad to see but they brought that
back as a prize to the youngsters who
then played with it and ripped it apart
and just did their thing and eventually
after some serious attention and
movement and thoughts and deliberation
the adults going backwards it forwards
up and down checking in every direction
they eventually took the puppies one by
one to the scene of the crime and the
puppies approached a very cautiously
very tentatively and we can only assume
not having seen it before with these
ones that it might be the first actual
kill that they've been taken to and that
else go off ahead and make the kill the
youngsters kind of stay back and then
the adults once they've made a kill come
back and get them after gorging
themselves of course and regurgitating
their meat for the youngsters as
obviously more meat to be had at the
scene of the crime and so they went back
with the youngsters who had pretty much
eaten everything that they drew Gurjit
ate it so there was not much left to the
adults got into it with apps
Aleut interest and the youngsters well
first time at a proper kill had to learn
that there's a different table manners
at the kill then there is at when
they're begging when the adults come
back there's very different table
manners poorly you want to know where
the dogs are dating well I believe it
was up in the Manya lady which is sort
of passed before sook and just on to the
left the money lazy also joins to the
Kruger to the north of it and at summer
party so sort of Northey North West's of
of where we are in Juma not farther
I'm say five K's or maybe six KS at the
most kilometers so to naff three miles
maybe but I'm not sure exactly we don't
get the opportunity to go that far north
so we're not sure but we heard about it
we were very excited I saw a little bit
of a spill on on on the show of Taylor
with the wild dogs and I I thought uh
what are the chances of me seeing them
and then first pretty much first morning
out there they were the eagle eyes of a
VM spotted them sitting in the open on a
termite mound we moved in an airplane
with a Steinbach head and then chasing
off the hyena which was so special to
see the pups learning so many so many
lessons well the migration I don't think
is completely over Scott is still
looking at animals that are moving to in
front with his Velda biased in the Mora
hogs came back to visit on Juma wonder
how long it was since they were last
there before they brought their pups
along look at all these wildebeest this
is probably the highest concentration of
wildebeest I've seen this migration and
it's absolutely wonderful to see now
that's just a tiny little portion of
them believe it or not we'll try and
show you a few more later my name's
Scott some teams up teamed up with James
kymo Emory thee on camera today and
we've come into this area because you
are hoping to find the sausage tree
pride and there are some new additions
that we are hoping that we are gonna
find today why don't you take a look at
our first ever glimpse of them earlier
in the week
after much anticipation finally the
missing member of the sausage tree pride
reunited with two lioness and we had our
first ever sighting of these two little
cuties we couldn't have asked for a more
magical setting for our first
introduction to them and the golden
light made it that much better
not only that but also the fact that
they were on the move and the two little
fur balls were in a very playful mood
[Music]
even mama was getting caught up in the
antics
[Music]
interestingly in the short time we spent
with them
it was immediately evident that one of
the Cubs was more poor than the other I
also managed to get a few glimpses below
their little tails and it seems to me
like they could well be two young boys
let's hope these two little guys make it
through this dangerous stage of their
lives little critters and sadly we
haven't seen them since that day and I
just like to kind of fill you in this is
where the sausage tree pride hangouts
until about three months ago there were
almost always in this very kind of small
area relatively speaking and then all of
a sudden some new line disappeared we're
thinking from the south and I'm guessing
it was the pressure from those lioness
as well as the fact that migrating herds
had made their way up into this area of
the reserve the kind of frontrunners
that the sausage tree pride moved all
all way across to here out of their
territory
and they've been hanging out there ever
since now we saw those little Cubs
somewhere around here going across this
road that was the last place we saw them
this two males in this area and that
will kill those Cubs so I'm hoping that
the lioness to lioness and the mother
caught wind of that and have come
somewhere back into the central area I'm
guessing that they are still lioness
here that of course the the lioness to
move and we'll the sausage tree prior to
move but we don't know thanks James we
don't know exactly why or how exactly
the dynamics work but that's kind of my
theory as to why I've come into this
area
it sounds like you guys have been having
a wonderful supply this afternoon
everyone seems to be getting lucky and
some really fascinating interactions are
pure in the Mara with old Kapoor Lee I
must say I'm quite envious of David and
Manu Skaar Doody those little Vienna
sausages you cover his Cubs are very
precious and they certainly are and we
kind of had a feeling well you're hoping
that we're gonna see some cups because
one line is disappeared for quite some
time
we actually saw her once rejoined the
pride about a month ago so she obviously
came to touch bases with them but the
Cubs weren't big enough to reintroduce
or introduce to that other pride members
just yet so we're not too sure how many
days before and we saw those first
little Cubs that she may have introduced
them to those other two lioness and
there's also a possibility that kinky
tail and the fifth lioness haven't even
met those Cubs yet because they've been
kind of doing their own thing
interesting times there's no two ways
about that possibly the first
interactions between kapoor lee and anna
we know lioness being seen today it's
definitely I think our first
interactions so yeah a lot is changing
and making our lives interesting which
is wonderful we just don't need to try
and keep our finger on the pulse which
is tricky
because they have got so much space to
roam and relatively not too many roads
for us to search but my plan tonight is
to stay out until midnight and hopefully
after dark but maybe a bit of audio and
vocalizations we may be able to get on
top of what is going down
but anywhere here those liners could
poke their head out of the grass and
feeling lucky about this area very good
well speaking of David and Kapoor Lee
and the big lady from there we know
pride why don't you go and see what the
latest developments are there well Scott
has been following the sausage 'try
pride for quite some time with branch
Leo Smith and I think this time around
is me who is lucky to be following them
and I've seen some of the dramatic
behavior of Puli the male that you see
the on the screen then I think the two
of them more than Brent and more than
scurry as it said earlier he has been
involved in two fights and in first my
apologies because I was hunted by
gremlin salya and you lost me at one
point I truly apologize and it's all
about technology and what's happening
now the having arrest keep fully with
the female lioness there and we can
identify that female lion as a hundred
percent but she belongs to the pride of
my own that we call the winners winners
always five the two youngsters their two
young females and this is the mother of
those two young females how lucky is
Kapali to fight off two males and now he
caught the girl for himself
well we might be lucky to see some
action
JW before I answer your question let me
pause for a few seconds or minutes
[Music]
I'm breathing out and JW I don't know
whether you got an answer from that
particular behavior of those lions
but while mating JW would have noticed
they don't hunt it's a very religious oh
it's like a ritual for them they
strictly keep - meeting religiously
without involving themselves in hunting
they might stay in the spot for like
five days not eating and not drinking
anything JW will he believe that if you
look carefully on the right eye of
Kapoor Lee he got a huge scar right
below the eye right eye and this he got
about an hour and a half ago
very fresh wound and is when he was
fighting the second of the male or the
nomadic males that had tried encroach
his territory and that male that has
given him that huge scar was meeting
with his female what I'm saying in other
words this female has been meeting with
two lions in the last I would say five
hours what is a strong female from the
OE nose
Jenica Kapali translates to an earring
and you have seen how people now will
have earrings on their ears or on their
noses so if you look over be like at one
point to see this male facing us that we
call key pulley you'll see what I'm
talking about when we look at his nose
so key pulley basically translates to an
earring and depending on why you put it
we think this may lie on have his
earring on the nose you can see how the
wind it's blowing or the winds blowing
his men and I think now she or they have
met at five times for the last 40
minutes and it's always exciting when
you see some real egos yes well not that
reinfect David but in fact what is
happening at the moment is love is
certainly in the air
males mating male and female lions
mating this warburg Eagle pair that has
just turned all the way back from North
Africa has come down here for the
breeding season and there's a little bit
of ello grooming going on right now it's
a female on the right and the male on
the left
she's noticeably bigger than he is and
while we've been waiting for you to come
to us he's been doing some proper head
scratchers for her very nice to see he
came in and landed beautifully on that
perch next to her probably be not
foraging looking for some food you
didn't bring anything back for her
because they're not actually nesting yet
they've well they've produced the nest
it seems that the nest just above them
there but I don't think there's any eggs
so far and we're hoping to maybe catch a
Gore mating wouldn't that be special I
don't think I've ever seen it before
definitely the spring summertime is on
its way and you can see that it's now
his turn for some head scratchers
but she's now giving him the attention
and now she dips her head to say my turn
now he's like no it's still my turn
constantly happening in relationships
it's everyone else's turn to do that the
tickling isn't it those hard-to-reach
places very important in these kind of
social standings for these birds some
mammals as well to do sort of ello
grooming it's a sustained us between
them its bonds them together and we're
looking forward to spending the summer
with these guys watching them reproduce
hello Ted well in the Warburg's eagle
which is very interesting they only lay
one egg very early too so they don't
seem to have the insurance policy that
most eagles do there do you lay the one
but that's only to have quite a good
success rate but if that it doesn't
hatch
well they might lay another one but
sometimes it's unlikely due to the short
sort of breeding season that they have
down here and then I mean last year this
pee I do believe it was this pair that
didn't successfully breed if this this
last season if I'm not mistaken there
was a pair closer to two Voigt Ella
watching all that that was successful we
watched that chick fledge and fly off
but this pair who knows what happened
it's hard to see what goes on in the
nest to be marvelous to set up some form
of camera ride up above but anyway we're
going to move on from my Eagles and
their love affair and let's go over to
the little chief and see how it's
getting on with his Impala me a grooming
is one of the very interesting
activities because it does maintain a
very strong relationships amongst bears
and other big animals so now I am still
here with the little chief or son and
I'm not alone at the moment at the
sighting I do have some other vehicles
also enjoying this majestic beautiful
cat and you can see now the prey that we
earlier on looking very much pretty
fresh now is looking very much damaged
is looking old now so this Kurt he
doesn't want to rest after killing this
animal I just want to eat straight away
I'm sure he has been raining a lot that
not feeding immediately the chances of
losing the kill they are always very
much hi
he is really improving everyday
so we have seen it on several occasions
when
Kangana is coming and take away the food
so now it was to kill and eat
immediately he doesn't want problems
anymore look at that now
so he's busy now trying to eat the
thighs he's eating the hip bones Lara
that is determined by the distance
between this animal and the competitors
such as the highness when we arrived
here we have arrived both at the same
time with the highness
but those hyenas they seems to be now
hiding somewhere around here if we if we
lose this they pray now I can promise
you the chances of getting it back they
are very much slim at the moment as
hyenas can be very much active to react
after the dropping of the killer
Steve with a chancy service honor to
move the kill to a different tree they
are very much hi I have seen was on a
moving occurs from one tree to the next
not long time ago husana conducted quite
a lot of series of hunting activities
and he managed to catch the three
different carcasses in less than 24
hours and that day I saw him moving to
the next tree with another piece of meat
left from a different animal you can see
now that meat looks very fresh and
moisturize Rosalind the tale of asana
can be very long up to 94 to 100
centimeters that is very much love so
that tail is not there for a decoration
the tail is there for communication and
is also there in order to show you the
level of aggression when this animal is
not happy so you can be able to read the
internal mood of the animal just from
the tail and it also serve in order to
call the little ones the little ones si
follow me sign to follow them when they
are going in between the bushes and
within the tall grasses look at that you
can see that his claws are very much
strong because he can be able to
maintain the balance
look at that positioning that is an
awkward position but you can see is
surviving it
so you can see that this is quite a very
lovely shirt and thank you very much
sensor so this leopard is not yet a
mature word still have got to go a long
way
it must be older than at least older
than two and a half years but to breed
he must have to start doing the building
activities when he's older than four
years so you can see that is a male we
can see the confirmation from a distance
he cannot drop that piece there on
papers he can only just drop some of the
pieces such as bones that are very
difficult to digest those kind of
unwanted small pieces yes he can be able
to drop them but the rest of the meat
and specifically the intestine is very
interested on if we can check there now
you can see there is a small piece that
is hanging and this son flies on that
was part of the things that he just
dropped earlier on when he was absorbing
in the stomach juices so those were part
of the unwanted materials because they
were very close to the end I think those
were the last the last droppings for
this animal which was in the body so he
did not want to eat that but it managed
to absorb the stomach juices
so now let's go back to the Masai Mara
aware as God has got the lovely Velda
beast my favorite animal during the my
garage our activities good idea Hosanna
it sounded like you weren't gonna be
able to keep your meal where you wanted
it
I'll just stopped here in and amongst
the herds and I'm hoping you can hear
them
[Music]
canoeing away the interesting thing when
you when you move through an area like
this that's just littered with
wildebeest is that quite often the Lions
can be nearby I'm told you sadly can't
really hear them too well but like I was
saying the lion could be dotted
somewhere in and amongst them and it's
often quite a bizarre scene having
credits are so close to the canoes but
for now we're gonna keep moving and see
if we can't check over this little rice
yeah
we need to rush you off to Steve goodbye
hello look at what we found my favorite
animal in the whole world from a
distance I thought I saw a very large
monitor lizard but it has in fact a
honey badger that is digging his nose
into this dead very dead tree I'm gonna
try exciting is that so excited I don't
quite know what to say right now hey
guys he's on the floor again v there he
is and he's moving quickly honey badgers
normally just don't stand still he's
gonna come right to us
this is my first honey badger in drama I
am so excited
and normally honey badgers just
disappear this guy doesn't seem too
bothered at all I can't believe it has
just made my ear seen the wild dogs this
week and now a honey badger on Sunday so
one of my favorite weeks ever here we go
that's the typical honey badger gate
always stay down again and he's moving
through he's gonna cross the road in
front of us in a second we get a nice
sort of image of him now sniffing as he
goes there he goes that's the honey
badger movement and I can keep that up
for a very long period of time how
fantastic he's got a really really good
sense of smell
not quite sure what he's looking for but
could be looking for insects scorpions
snakes he was climbing up on the tree
and maybe he was looking for something
that stuck as a snuck itself away into
one of the cavities every run is also
very excited like being let's see if we
can get him again he's looking very
relaxed so all about the route that you
choose to go
we have been have had no luck with the
wild dog tracks so we trying to follow
up on where we last saw the lion tracks
and there goes the honey badger there
Paula honey badgers are regarded as
crepuscular so active at dusk and dawn
but then none of these animals really
fits into their category if that weather
is quite cool they can really do
anything they want to but primarily the
active witness the coolest parts of the
day and this guy is as well it's cooled
down a bit he's probably quite hungry it
almost looks like his hips are sticking
out it looks like he might be extremely
hungry maybe lost a little bit of
condition that he's gone into a little
thicket there we have another road to
our left-hand side that might work quite
well
oh no idea joy I haven't identified the
FDF it's a male or a female I don't
really care to be honest that is a honey
badger and that makes us be so excited
but I suppose maybe I said he are just
I'm so confused or so excited that I've
maybe mixed up a little bit of the wrong
language it is I'm trying to get myself
in a good position I think if I just
move around this little thicket here he
is playing a very nice game with us here
I believe James Henry had the most
amazing honey badger sighting for the
longest period of time there he is there
it is I'm just Marcy honey badgers are
omnivores they in the order carnivora so
they do eat meat they're specialists at
snakes scorpions the absolutely love bee
honey comb from beehives insect they are
feed on small rodents as well they're
dig things up yeah anything that might
be trying to hide away small mammals
small birds eggs and they can climb
trees nothing really can escape them and
you know they have a fetish for for bees
and bee hives hence the name honey
badger and they seem to be immune to the
stings of the bees a very thick fur and
very thick pliable skin make them very
very resilient even to a leopard a lion
might kill them quite easily but a
leopard well my leopard thinks twice
about trying to tackle these individuals
but this is what they do they're just
ferreting around constantly busy
constantly digging around smelling
sniffing searching for whatever they can
go for looking for scorpions underneath
the bark sniffing maybe he's got some
rodent trails he's picking up on or
maybe one of the black numbers that's
been moving around has left some support
of sort of pheromone trail along the
ground that it's picked up on and is
moving towards I'm over the moon
oh yes Kathy Kathy Ohio honey badgers
are regarded as being quite aggressive
and that is their form of defense
basically because they they are mustelid
so they're able to secrete quite a
smelly enzyme and their best form of
defense is just to be aggressive and to
fight so to challenge anybody who tries
to get in their way and through that
most predators and most animals learn
that the honey badger is not to be
toiled with so invariably they leave
them alone maybe a young male or a young
leopard might end up playing with the
honey badger once but then once bitten
twice shy they'll end up leaving it be
it's just in a little thicket here again
it's gonna come out the other side here
we go he's got a snake oh my word
he's got a snake who's got a snake I
think it's a puff adder I don't know was
my peon monitor lizard he's got
something that moved through there look
at the size of it it might be a monitor
lizard he is grabbing it by the tail it
could be a snake I have no idea just saw
something move very quickly and there it
goes
let's see if we can keep up with him
monitor lizard up the tree he's going up
after it the monitor lizards right on
top he's climbing it like a Pooh Bear
the monitor lizard has got absolutely no
chance here folks this is what the honey
badger does best
oh he's jumped down he is going to try
the monitor lizard is in a safe spot
right now I don't think the honey badger
can climb that tree oh my word
this is happening directly in front of
us a lot of folks that monitor lizard I
think is having a huge sigh of relief
he had his tail in the jaws of the honey
badger and honey badger just before we
came around to the spot lifted his tail
like that when his tail goes up like
that that's when he gets excited he must
do something similar he's going to try
again I wonder they are very clever they
are very good at figuring things out and
he's going to try to figure out how to
get that monitor lizard the monitor
lizard is sitting perched very
precariously on a very thin stalk of a
tree and I don't know he knows that he's
no match
he's going to just try to stay there but
I wonder if this very clever carnival is
going to figure out how to get up there
definitely where he picked his tail up
before he must have noticed or smelt
that something was here he was up a tree
earlier when we first found him and
maybe that was the smell of the monitor
lizard that he initially found or smelt
and he's been trying to track it and
follow at the monitor lizzard would be
moving in very similar sort of manner to
the honey badger looking for things and
crevices
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Juma in the sabi sands where
we have got a very excited and very
energized honey badger that has been
ferreting around in the undergrowth and
sniffing after something we weren't
quite sure what it then
all of a sudden launched an attack
caught this individual monitor lizard -
by the tail and the monitor lizard who
is very very strong was able to pull
himself out of the grasp of the honey
badger ran up a very big log and has now
perched precariously on a very thin
branch a honey badger is moving around
in all sorts of circles he is a very
smart fella they're able to figure
things out and he's going to see if he
can somehow displace that monitor lizard
from his perch on top of the tree now
he's going up the actual tree that the
monitor lizards in they are very good
climbers and what's going to happen is
if he does get up there the monitor
lizards going to feel he's being
threatened he's probably going to jump
out and the honey badger will basically
probably jump down and chase him I don't
think this is going to end well for the
lizard please feel free to drop your
questions and comments below Jonathan
Wow indeed he is well honey badgers are
my favorite animal in the world and this
is my first time seeing one in probably
about a year and a half first time
seeing one here on Juma look at how he
goes he does not care there goes the
monitor lizard down it goes on the floor
the chase is on folks the chase is on go
honey badger I'm going to move up fully
honey badgers tail is in the air he's
very excited if he catches this I don't
know what he's going to do is he going
to try a throttle it yeah he's got it
right over here
how's that for thee you'll answer we
love showing you our broadcast welcome
from Toronto here we have the honey
badger he has just made the kill of what
looks like a rock monitor it's hard to
say I want to think I want to try
reposition for you voldie
just put my nose in the bush here real
quick holy moly everyone this is
incredible stuff that's about as good as
we're going to do if just put our nose
off the road here wing nut well the
honey badger preys on whatever he wants
to and martial Eagle actually also very
very good predator for monitor lizards
larger monitors are also good predators
against the younger ones but the honey
badger has dispatched him he has
probably snapped his neck when he caught
him the monitor after that drop onto the
floor I think everything was over for
him there there's no escape I've seen
honey badgers taking Cape Cobras out of
trees
I've seen them killing a rock pythons
that are six seven times larger than
them without any effort it's all about
attitude there we go it's positioned
itself perfectly for us
what a fantastic sighting it's quite an
old the nerman honey badgers don't care
we'll leave the expletive out of it this
time
you can there's a little bit of cracking
of bone now for some reason he's
enjoying eating the face not quite sure
why a little bit of monitor lizard
tongue Michelle it is my favorite animal
and I'm glad that you love them too they
are fearless and monitor lizards to try
and grab one it's quite a thing to do
they are very powerful and the honey
badger caught it by the tail initially
and tried to pull it out of the tree or
out of the bush that it was in it
managed to wrap its tail and knock a
honey badger off and then scuttled up
that little bush which the honey badger
then chased it up and you saw how the
honey badger figured it all out and once
the monitor was on the ground it was all
over but the eating
Maria that's a great question and the
honey badger will probably eat his
favorite portions and then I don't think
he'll be able to ingest the entire
lizard the lizard is probably about half
of his weight maybe a third of his
weight which is an enormous amount of
meat to get in but I'm thinking that
this individual honey badger is quite
old you can see it's got quite a bit of
sort of mange or it's losing fur under
the legs we saw earlier was losing a bit
of fur and it's teeth aren't really
doing
I suppose what it needs to do but maybe
he just likes the lips of a monitor
lizards but he's not really breaking
into it I keep saying he I do apologise
I have no idea what sex it is at the
moment
Cristina do you see those claws there
the claws are for digging and for
climbing and they climb trees very very
well I mean he climbed the tree earlier
he looked like a black bear you might
find in the the northern hemisphere or
in the States and he climbs the tree
very very well and they connect you go
up the trees quite quickly nowhere near
as well as leopards can do but they're
quite strong quite powerful the claws
aren't necessarily very sharp but
they're able to add purchase just like
black bears do when they climb a tree
and it enables them to pull their full
bodyweight up but they can go up trees
all right diligently and he went up that
small tree and onto the end of that
precarious branch without any fear and I
think I was watching him at the time and
not the monitor but I think you might
have all caught him just launching
himself out of the air probably about
two and a half three meters in the air
he's landed on his side on its side
after the monitor lizard not standard
all most of us would be and be
completely winded with a fall like that
especially we knew the size of an imager
like this and then there we go now he's
well I think he's enjoying his meal very
strange to see what part he goes for
first maybe he's just so angry that the
monitor lizard resisted him initially
that he's just going to eat its face
first
well ladies and gentlemen we are still
live on YouTube please feel free to
Google us a safari live a jump on board
we still have for another hour or so we
will be here again next week and every
other day on YouTube so thank you for
joining us at this short action
broadcast and we will see you next time
have a good evening
Wow I'm out of breath there folks I'm
out of breath well who needs to find
lions and leopards to get action how
exciting is an individual like there's
something I'm really really amazed at
the opportunity that this guy is taking
this individual is taking and not really
getting too much of the food in the
still hasn't really removed much of the
face at the moment there's a blood on
the on the lip
if there are sensitive viewers out there
might not be a good time to watching now
but this is nature and this is what
happens out yep they're not them you see
the teeth are quite well worn down can
you see that another good indication of
age that might be another reason why
struggling to really feed but they are
tenacious full of spirit and it was so
awesome to see because he was moving
around with his nose on the ground he
was very deliberately trying to find
something that had been around and he
went up the first tree which is a
typical sort of tree for for a monitor
lizard to be in and then he just picked
up the smelt picked up the trail found
it underneath the bush and that was the
end as it were of a very nice example of
a monitor lizard well from one carnival
to the next one kill sooner that let's
get a Sydney and a little chief it was
really nice watching the small carnivore
after the Rev tires a very aggressive
animal now I've got one of the big
spotted horse on is now very relaxed on
the ground now all the way from the
acacia tree now you can see he came down
all the way from the tree to the termite
mound he's very relaxed now so he's
gonna gain quite a lot of strength and
again go up to the tree and carry on
feeding so I don't know oh now he's
moving oh is just changing the sports
you can hear his coughing I'm sure may
be here by the throat they still quite a
little fast from the fresh kill
earlier this week we saw a very lovely
sighting of Tigana we found it in Ghana
late one afternoon staring into a
distance they were rumors that he had
been with a female leopard who was quite
shy and not fond of the vehicles
Kangana made an interesting contact call
before resting up in the long grass
I wasn't long before the young Lepidus
came slinking out from behind a bush and
presented herself to Tanana we were so
lucky fortunate to witness the cats made
on two different occasions however the
young female is not familiar with
vehicles and suspect she may have come
from the north near Buffalo
it was interesting thinking on
introducing his new girlfriend here in
Duma and it's an unknown girlfriend
I'm sure ting Ghana was looking for her
son and tiny to show them he's got a new
girlfriend and he decided to just made
in front of us to make sure that the
here domestic that is not have they are
not just friends
it's about mating activities it's
definitely a new wife so you can see Oh
sir today now they're very nice and
relaxed let's see maybe he's gonna go up
back to the killer and carry on feeding
so the competition is very much low at
the moment as the Highness are not here
at the moment sons from Israel a day
kill is right up earning by the tree I
can see it from here he managed to find
a very nice spot in order to hang the
carcass but where it is I can promise
you is well protected because it's not
just by a simple tree this is an acacia
tree is a chilli a tree the tree which
has got quite a lot of spikes on them is
in in is inaccessible at the moment only
him can access that carcass but the
other case such as Tandy Antigone if
they come here obviously they will be
able to get hold of these carcass at
home when the unknown female caught some
calms you must have to make sure that
the Cubs are well hiding away from the
other females as the mortalities can be
very much much high so the females don't
tolerate the other females it's just
like the males as well don't tolerate
other males only the opposite sex can be
tolerated
so that cat that we saw king animating
with the unknown cat we not too sure
where she's coming from maybe she's just
here in this territory for mating
purposes and after that we'll go back
give birth and raise young but I'm sure
ting Ghana knows where exactly that
female is from it was very nice seeing
ting and introducing that female to us
so now let's go back to the Masai Mara
de vide has got another big cat he is
now having a group of lions so I will be
here with you asana just to see what's
gonna happen
I would be happy to compete in Ghana
with Kapali
I don't Sydney would be talking of
husana having a girlfriend or hasana
meeting with a female Lepidus or female
a bird but apparently not so here we
have pulley as the male in charge of
this area and he is the one meeting we
initially had one of the nomadic melons
that was met him with that female that
you see there and Kay pulley as the male
there
just those two males out one in the
morning and the other one in the
afternoon and he took over
nashwa he is now retired because of old
battles he had he had two major battles
today I would say one with the battery
in the afternoon because in the morning
it was more of a chase than a battle and
of course since I've been here he has
netted a thing about seven times mano or
eight young man who thinks eight I had
counted seven I don't know a Manticore
the eighth came from
maybe now the ninth let's wait and see
if it was seven is with eighth time it
was eight to go to the ninth time now
and with the Lions unlike other animals
once she's ready but to matically the
mayor should just met
well part of that the ground from the
female is because she gets hurt by the
male because the male's penis is hooks
backwards and is bit spiky of spiny and
as it's finishing oh when he is with
druid out of the vagina its tends to
heart the walls of it and that's where
most likely the female have to react in
a way that I'm not very happy as much as
we finished because you've you know hurt
me Wow which meant again maybe not if
you look on the right eye
all right below the right eye is he a
huge scar there and he fully got that
scar today on the bottle in the
afternoon because the first nomadic lion
he just chested and it kept going and
going but on this particular here the
second well it did not go away he stood
his ground and he wanted to remain there
and keep fighting and when Lions fight
there's a lot of coin and there's a lot
of teasing and at the end of the day
those are some of the results that you
get and as much as he is a winner every
victory have some sacrifices and I think
not to say he's weak on his right side
because we call him a pulley if we're
lucky to see his nose closely he got a
little split on the right side of the
nose and incidentally he got that scar
on the right side so maybe that is his
Blind Side and the scar that he got way
back look at that nose there money we
punch on that nose very good Manu you
can see a slight split on the right side
of that nose and apparently I'm not sure
why the coincidence he got the scar on
the right eye as I said earlier maybe
this could be the Blind Side for Kapoor
Lee will always have a weak sides and
maybe he was not very quick to protect
that part
Patricia we have a classical example of
one leonesse today and that particular
lioness you see there Patricia
meting with two lions in the last out
say six hours when we saw in the morning
she was meeting with a younger male
which we had not seen before and Khopoli
the bell on the right there was watching
from a distance when we went back to
camp and came back here in the afternoon
Kapali chased off the male that was
meeting with her and he pulley has taken
over so Patricia across for example it
is one lioness meeting with two math yes
lionesses will mate with two sometimes
three different males during the time
there in history what are you thinking
she just moved about 6 8 meters away
from Khopoli but surprisingly she keeps
looking the direction where the other
male sat after the fight was done
Reuben I'll tell you Kapali will okay
Polly has to quality myths that have not
been around for the last two days we've
been in the morning and who initially
thought when the battle started this
afternoon
or when he fully had to chase away the
other mail he starts Carly on the right
is this car been talking about we
thought his partners in the quality
would come and give him hand and we
never saw them but should they come
around they have some protocol amongst
themselves that Khopoli is in charge and
chances are they will not fight him or
he unified them to keep the meeting
right here met until hopefully this
female will conceive and get pregnant so
that this come talking about we have
another lion not very far from here and
at the coalition of lions and there's
one that you call his coffees and
hopefully now this will not bring
confusion because he got a scan not in a
very different area than what you can
see on key pulley now you just try to
have a snooze Kabuli very well done
today your photo of two young but very
strong male ions you won the battle and
you're still in very good shape to keep
meeting you must be a very sad boy but
very well done and you have gotten your
place right back and let's find out what
is the latest from Scotty
I'm very happy that Kapoor Lee has
managed to find himself some new ladies
the reason being is that some of his old
ladies seemed to found some new men
there have been some other interesting
developments with the sausage tree pride
kinky tail and one other have been
mating with the old Daniel Pike males
who are dominance over the turf where
the ladies have recently started hanging
arts
this is about five miles west of their
usual territory where kapu Lee and his
partner used to oversee them
we are not sure why kinky tell Anna
pride have moved West my guess would be
pressure from another pride as opposed
to the lure of the migrating herds which
are plentiful in their old turf
interesting times ahead and of course
also the very exciting prospects of two
new sets of curves being born in about
three months time
[Music]
so interesting stuff they're not just
kinky tail but as I said another one of
the lioness was mating with the bigger
more impressive male from the old Anya
pi ik male the gar kinky tail chose has
got a bit of a receding hairline is not
as impressive as his partner those two
ordinarily we've seen in the only times
I've ever seen them they've actually
been with the old on your pi ik pride of
12 a big pride but sadly they're very
skittish so not very welcoming when it
comes to viewing them interesting it was
probably a hundred metres down this road
where we saw kinky tail mating with the
one guy and they Spence abouts but a
week in this general area not moving far
at all
they had a kill under one of these trees
I remember they managed to snipe a
wildebeest at some point in time and
midway through their session some hoping
that they're still lurking somewhere
here possibly down in the dip which is
another area where we saw them kind of a
month or so ago they Bank it down in one
spot with and then it's quite easy for
us to find them for about a week our
Lara Moy you would like to know if it's
possible for a set of Cubs to have
multiple fathers within the same sets it
is actually possible but unlikely with
lions it's more probable with leopard
because female leopard unknown should
spend one day mating with one guy and
then find another guy mate with them and
that way try and make all of them think
that they are in fact the father won't I
guess they could be
and that's why I'm told you can get
father's different father's for the same
litter of Cubs but with lions it's
uncommon because the lioness will
usually stay with the males they are
mating with for the duration of their
three to five days of mating now I must
say I cannot wait to look back at the
footage that you guys were lucky enough
to witness live with Steve and that
honey badger why don't you see how much
it's managed to plow through that
monitor lizard yes well it is the most
bizarre thing folks the honey badger is
still eating the face of this monitor
lizard and every now and again the body
of the monitor lizard moves we're not
sure if it's just bit there we go watch
it I don't know if it's still alive or
if the honey badgers may be pulling
certain tendons in the neck but he
hasn't really done too much eating he's
basically eaten off the lower jaw they
had the tail still moving it's very very
very very sad to see if you're sensitive
you are look away now
there is a reptile I don't know what
sort of pain threshold he has but you
can see that the face is almost
completely gone and yet the body is
still spasming from time to time that is
sometimes quite hard to watch so
thinking that monitor maybe was playing
shy for a while and hoping for chance to
escape but honey badgers got both of its
claws latched on and its jaws latched on
as well and hopefully it'll soon put
this poor creature out of its misery
remember folks this is live coming to
you from the African wilderness where
these things happen predator eats prey
in this case predator eats predator
monitor lizard wouldn't think twice
about devouring the eggs of a baby bird
or even the baby chicks
kellen I don't actually kill him I don't
actually have an exact weight
measurement for you there but it's
probably equivalent to that of a
medium-sized dog of about the same sort
of size it's not necessarily the
strength of the jaw that makes that any
better powerful it's the fact that they
are just aggressive they basically just
chase anyone down they intimidate
absolutely anyone and that is where they
win
art in this area because everything
shires away from the honey badger I
wouldn't necessarily say that they would
bite you extremely painfully I think the
bite will be saw but that's similar to
that of a small dog I don't think it's
got the powerful jaw biting force of
that of a lot of the other animals that
we have named in a leopard and lion but
if we've seen the skull in in the tent
before that James has shown that I've
shown it once or twice the the area left
open for the brain to fit into the
cavity in the brain of the honey badger
in the skull is enormous in comparison
to that of other animals it's probably
far bigger than that of most the animal
pet encounter even for their body size
as so as this individual was trying to
figure out how to get some on the
monitor lizard out of the tree it was
using its very very large brain to just
work things out
well from a once again a small carnival
to another carnivore in this time a very
very special sighting for those of you
haven't been with us during the week
Sydney and Taylor came across something
very special in the heart of Zuma
and look at this animal this is quite
lovely I have got the highness here with
me now I can just see two of three of
them I can see the two others and a
small little one just inside the den
this is a new den
earlier this week were very lucky to
come across a new Dan in Duma this week
Taylor located a few Hainan foods it was
then discovered that they had a den
nearby
I made my way into the area to
investigate and indeed there was a large
female Hina
and they all den on film on costly it
was confirmed that this Hina is called
Koki and the den was definitely active
since then we have had some incredible
views of Koki and her tiny little black
cub finally we have another den on June
it has been very interesting remarkable
seeing the new den in humid this is
something very very rare it's always
amazing to come across such a lovely dan
in a game reserve you can see that there
we've got the mother right by the door
behind the mother is a small baby still
very much duck and she's just coming in
and out I can see now that the little
one is having some milk on the other
side lovely I haven't seen something
like this before I only started seeing
activities like this since last week
shortly after this Dell has been
discovered
just want to see if maybe we can be able
to see the little one coming back again
so the little one is now alright inside
maybe it's gonna come out again and say
hi to us so the animal such as highness
the s-curve angels and when having
little ones they look after each other
others will have to go and get the food
and bring back to the den so that the
remaining ones can eat and also mothers
can go out come back and regurgitate the
food and give this food to their little
ones Highness when they are born little
ones are already well equipped they've
got teeth they can see they can walk
which is amazing they are always ready
and to engage with an others look at
those canines those are the canines used
in order to crush bones this is one of
the animals which has got a powerful
powerful jaws and powerful canines
so this little one is going to settle
for about over a year to 18 month car is
the hyenas they do scavenge more than
hunting they are not very successful
hunters so they've got to depend on
quite a lot of other carcasses left
overs from the hyenas and from the other
big cats but when it comes to the cats
such as the leopard is always difficult
because they hang their food by the tree
but sometimes they lose them and that is
when they get a chance so the little one
was just out there let's see now maybe
could have come in between the legs they
look at the little one right there is
coming you can see that the little one
listen to that they are now starting to
greet each other they might go through a
ceremonial greeting which is totally
different from all these other species
so that one just went a deep in the hole
which is good if the little one has
learned that every time they pick up
something that you have to get
disappeared as here on the ground they
can be so vulnerable you can see now
that they are going through their
ceremonial greeting with a very
beautiful sunset on the background look
at that and this is a beautiful picture
thank you very much sensor for such a
beautiful shot you can see that is a
lovely lovely sunset so let's hope the
little one is gonna come back again and
play with the mom so now let's go back
to the Masai Mara David is also having
something interesting at the moment not
too sure what animal has got so far but
he's got something Kapoor Lee is now
having a commercial break maybe waiting
for the next time they're going to start
meeting and it's pretty wonderful
exciting news to hear I am sure is it
Sydney who found out a high in a den in
Juma in South Africa that was pretty
exciting news and we have been having
higher than here of the north time that
you have been following for the last
many months mostly followed by Jaime
Patterson and how wonderful to talk
about highness and especially the Cubs
we arrived at the North plant community
to be greeted by the sight of an
adorable face peeking through the grass
for a moment we thought who are looking
at one of our first Cubs but we realized
we were wrong on the cub started
circling on a different female
the mother aggressed on another
individual a lesson for the youngster on
the errand king in the clan the captain
ative lee ventured out in open but
quickly - to safety when approached by
another individual the Cabrio merged
with another youngster and the two
continues to learn about shrunk by
socializing with other members in the
clan after night fell war first arrived
and her Cubs emerged out of the barrel
confirming that the two Cubs we had seen
that was still playing out of the den
for the newest additions to the north
clan now before Jamie Patterson who is
my colleague as the guide went on leave
I could be wrong but I think as she left
the community end of the Northland she
went knowing that waffles had two cups
but the good news is we have two more
cups and I think in total now we got
four now the one thing that I have to do
I got some homework to do and find out
who is the mother of the two cubs and
these two the Cubs are Lou younger than
the ones who office will guess maybe the
one for our fours were born sometimes
early August or maybe the second week of
August and they could be about six seven
weeks old and these two new additions of
bundles of joy they're much younger
maybe bear about two weeks not much of a
difference and my biggest joy will be
when I go back to the north plant high
in a den find out who the mother
actually is but so so interesting to see
two cups of one mother and then another
pair of Cubs just playing and
socializing this is very good our
foremost cups of most carnivores to come
out and play because it's quite cool and
I think on my way home I will swing by
the den and find out if anything could
be happening there
Cledus Adalia is quite exciting news to
have students both in Kenya and in South
Africa first my name I would say no I
would say both hyenas are ideally the
same size they are the same species that
we call the spotted hyenas oh the
laughing hyenas but I might
once the mark could be slightly larger
than the ones in Juma and also for the
Lions I could be wrong but let us look
at this lion as he is mating is slightly
like in size than the males in Duma
well very typical for a rollover of the
female lioness after meeting and I have
always thoughts maybe that helps to get
the salmon to their fabien tubes to be
able to conceive the little biting there
I think is always the pain as I had said
earlier asked the male with the drawers
he's Penny's because kind of spiny
inspect and it tends to heart in the
vagina of the female marking our
territory we can seek a pulley you
deserves to do that and you have done
some wonderful job for yourself today if
the practice is to be given key pulley
out of giving you the best a word and
talking of exciting days with exciting
sightings let's find out what Steve has
for us well we are still with the
beautiful honey badger and yes well as
sleet in the head and as we all should
well know and how it is disturbing to
see but some reptiles when they are dead
they still practically move but it's
still quite hard to watch when you see
animals legs flailing in the air trying
to sort of escape of being eaten even
though this caught but what in this
insane drive that has been so far mating
lions up in the north and we just missed
asana making a kill but a live honey
badger kill that is incredible that is a
first for me that's the longest time
I've ever spent with a honey badger in
the wild I think the most I've spend
with the honey badger is about 20 to 30
seconds before because they just move
and you cannot keep up with him and
their don't stick to rights they just
disappear but we could tell how this
individual was moving it was definitely
on the trail of something and when his
tail popped up in the air like that it
got very excited
and then the work was done a few people
are suggesting we should call this
Hannibal the honey badger
well that's a very good decision a very
good suggestion although Hannibal
the honey badger would probably be
eating a honey badger wouldn't he
kermy hello you want to know any badges
spend their time or where they live for
they live in little holes in the ground
they'll basically timeshare with hyena
and porcupine and all those sort of
things they're one of the many animals
that do live inside of burrows they're
created by aardvark
they do have you can see those claws
they're very good at digging so they can
go into a small hole that's been created
and dig it even deeper if they need to
they're very efficient diggers they
often are oh there's the tongue look at
the forked tongue they're sticking out
that's very interesting he hasn't eaten
the tongue yet it's got a blue tongue
now I often see a monitor lizard when
it's moving around it's flicking its
tongue out cuz it's bringing it all that
all the pheromones in the air into the
mouth which they're not accessed by the
organ of Jacobson which is in the roof
of the mouth you have found that in all
reptiles a lot of mammals have got it as
well the organ of Jacobson but the
snakes and reptiles are the most obvious
for it because everything in their
environment is communicated through what
they pick up on their tongue and very
interesting to see it from inside I know
it's quite disturbing folks but this is
quite a unique oh he's gone here we go
he's got the tongue up oh he quite enjoy
it
oh he's pulling it it's quite disturbing
to see but this is this is what happens
in nature nothing of this monitor lizard
what will be wasted that is the the back
of the throat now of that of the monitor
lizard he's eaten from the lips to the
cheeks to the jaws and I have seen the
tongue which was anchored to the back of
them up and down the throat and he seems
to be trying to eat it from the inside
out now you see a little bit of the jaw
still up on the top left there of the
teeth the at least the monitor lizard
has stopped moving for now which is is
quite less disturbing
Frances I have absolutely no idea why I
didn't start on the belly but what I do
know is I've found twice in my life
snakes that have been killed by honey
badgers one was an enormous large Python
and the honey badger just ate the head
and then left the rest and another time
was a puff adder if I recall he also ate
the head and then moved off so it's very
hard to understand what it is that that
going for maybe they know that the the
the facial region is the most dangerous
part of the animal and so they eat it
really don't know but Ivaldi that Python
you said Tenggara stole from an e badger
was it also the head only there was
eaten it can't remember so it's really
hard to say but I mean how many people
out there have seen honey badgers eating
things or with kills in my very limited
experience of finding honey badger kills
they always seems to eat the head mr.
public I don't know if I mean they would
dare try and come in here the honey
would come in and start sniffing it may
become a bit closer the honey badger
would lift its tail in excitement there
we go
he's busy chewing the last of the jaw
and he would charge the hyena and hyenas
are not used to that happening to them
down here actually Lions will chase them
but if anything small runs at a hyena
I'm pretty sure with the confidence that
they in zoo and that they carry with
them within aggression with a growl with
a snarl and the tail up very excited i
Haney would move off for sure we're
looking at it's not worth the effort
everything in life is about early
weighing up the costs weighing up is it
worth protecting is it worth fighting
for
same goes for all of the Predators is it
worth getting involved with just like
hasana probably got his kill up the tree
so as not to compete with hyena and if
one and did manage to get it would he
actually fought back let's go to Sydney
and see what his thoughts are
you can see now that wasana is pretty
much too relaxed but now right in front
of us are noways facing at the moment I
can see there is a hyena coming much
closer you will see he's going to appear
just now you can see this a movement
there behind those small bushes that is
the hyena coming to check what's
happening is right there they are all
now looking at each other
Hina is coming to see if there are any
viability zuv having something to eat
this afternoon so you can see now that
this Hina is now nice and clear you can
see it's going back okay this Hina
arrived here just about 2 minutes after
this kill has happened
it came earlier and check and sniff
around and go disappeared is coming back
here for the second time now
so the hyenas by this time of the night
is when they are deploying each other in
search of food and how they search for
food is interesting they do something on
the grasses which is called pasting
whereby you will find the two markings
one it will be milky white and the
bottom one mostly is milky dark the top
one is to communicate for territorial
purposes whereas the second marking is
for when they are looking for food if
another family member comes to that area
is going to sniff that grass and will
know that my brother already covered
this area it means I must have to go to
the other side so those are the markings
which are very important for them when
they are looking for food
Safari sorry the distance between
Hosanna and the high Nadine is
approximately a kilometer or less it's
not even a long distance but there by
the den I can promise you I don't think
asana will be able to visit the high in
a den as those hyenas always when seeing
them they are against wasana
so there's been quite a lot of history
between the hyenas which are residing by
the den and what's on always lying down
here so now let's go to the Masai Mara
David has got some male lions there I
haven't seen the male lions en Juma for
quite a long time last time I've seen
evoke us it was a long time ago
well that's very typical behavior of
predators one minute they're here the
other minute they're there
we now have ki Puli only so the other
predator is gone I don't know where she
went but she just wandered off to the
right and left us with Caputi so for
Sydney Seiler to move away it's very
common as they said for predators to do
the same and this is exactly what is
happening here with our meeting - but I
do it they have been meeting throughout
and the area we are in now here is an
area called the burnt area because there
was some fire here a few months ago and
when the fire died the rains came the
shortage the grass have been pretty
short and this short grass and the
openness of the area it makes the
tummies and other types of prey to come
around to enjoy the shorter grass which
is pretty nutritious and when that
happened also we see other predators
that would prefer to chase the Tommies
and feed on them
we found a Kenya sitting lot on top of a
salmon mound we quickly realized our
attention was on a group of Tommy's a
small distance away a quick stretch and
she started moving closer she was
spoiled for choice but she wisely chose
the Tommies a quick trot and she was off
but she took off too soon she missed the
target as he slunk away she seemed to
officiously
as if reevaluating adjectives for her
next hunt after a few days we caught up
with Kenya again missing with purpose
she soon revealed to us that this time
around she had been lucky in a hunting
she picked up the baby Tom Lee from the
shaded area and relocated it to an open
area out in open she could easily spot
any critters coming after settling in
she divided her breakfast
well I have known many cheaters in the
Mara and in do mine in South Africa but
I think a Kenya has a class the way she
hunts the way she brings down her prey
she does a pretty good job in general
you note his hyenas got about 40 50
percent success only hunts but for me I
would give Kenya 67 percent she wants
the whole like we saw there alia she did
not calculate very well but on a second
attempt she did very well so many times
it's Iike Kenya have always considered
her to be a very successful hunter as a
female our big boy key pulley is still
laying down they're not interested with
a female now who just wanted off but
just to remind you oh oh nice royal
viewers about our expeditions were over
other expeditions which opens maybe in
the next one our locally here in East
African time it opens the next five
minutes and from Central African time
it's going to open in the next day about
one hour please go on to that forum and
please book your spaces because it's
going to be an exciting thing to do from
next year and the for me is on
expeditions dot world earth dot TV so
they say Dahlia is opening up from six
o'clock and the book Kings will not be
accepted until around 6:30 so look at
the form and after about half an hour
you can start booking your swords for
that exciting world of expeditions well
darkness is slowly coming in here and
because of that we are wondering where
the female of Kapali has gone we might
go looking for her and because of the
darkness we may also be slowly and
surely be heading home of a such
wonderful exciting day and on behalf of
myself and Manu will take your cross to
Steve and we thank you very much and to
all of you have a very good one thanks
David Scott and the camera ops up there
thank you for your input
afternoon what a marvelous afternoon we
have had a honey badger has thought busy
feeding he's not pulling it out he wants
to maybe get a little bit in the open
and clearing there and so special to be
able to be spending time with this but
Elaine did we have a honey badger this
morning yesterday morning we were graced
with the opportunity of seeing the uncle
Homer pride who materialized on the
property after some time and they had a
little special surprise the uncle Homer
pride returns to Juma early on Saturday
morning
Taylor caught up with them around
treehouse dam in the golden afternoon
light the young uncle Homer male showed
some interest in a scrawny little Impala
dared to come down and drink with the
rest the pride seemingly uninterested
this was the young male who spent some
time weighing up the energy costs
involved in trying to catch such a small
prize
the Impala alone and clearly in poor
condition was left to wind off unharmed
to our surprise a new young male was
found with the pride males origin is
unknown but for now his presence within
the pride is being tolerated so who was
that young male look at this shot almost
as if the monitor lizard is holding on
to his head it's definitely dead just
popping on to the FLIR camera there and
this is the hot spotted thermal imaging
and you can see that the lizard is still
quite warm from the daily exertions he
still be an art and they the honey
badger has picked up his prize that who
knows where it is off to moving back in
to the thickets how fantastic is this
I'm just going to move up a little bit
more see if we can get one more glimpse
just on the side of the road here which
is very very special to be seen
then this is going to be the last the
last visual that we get of him hurt it's
I'm not sure it's going to go into a
little den site or so underneath there
how fantastic is this to be able to
spend all this time well Joe that's a
great question Eric and honey badgers
can live up to about the age of 15 16 in
the wild depending on all sorts of
conditions and competition I need to
double-check that fact but I'm guess I'm
thinking that's about the right sort of
age bracket but don't quote minute I
might not be hundred percent right but
ladies and gentlemen it has been a
marvelous afternoon and thank you for
joining us out here in the African
wilderness honey badger for the first
time in Juma with the kill of our
monitors that as sad as it might have
seemed that poor honey badger is
definitely going to be full and happy
with himself
this evening herself I keep saying in
the opposite if we can still see it
there is it coming out he once he's
probably hit it away now is going to
come back and maybe tell me to disappear
how beautiful is that ending the show
the honey badger I don't think we could
have scripted this any better thank you
to everyone from the Mara the FC and
everyone down here in Juma for their
cooperation in this edition of Safari
lavs thank you to you the viewers for
joining us once again and there's been a
marvelous afternoon we will see you next
week for the same show but don't worry
tomorrow morning live again with our
normal hour we'll see you then have a
fantastic evening